the true conflict of one punch man is
saitama's hopeless Obsession for just
another fun fight and his refusal to
move on with his life from that saitama
keeps saying that he's a hero for fun
and yet if there is one thing we know
about the strongest anime character ever
it's that he doesn't have a lot of fun
being one
the guy who right from the start has
everything that all other Shonen Heroes
dream of and desperately struggle for is
suffering from a dreadful existential
crisis because of this power but I feel
like people are surprisingly confused
about the point one punch man is trying
to make as a story it's not merely a
parody of conventionals Shonen and
superhero stories or merely a story
about what it means to be a good hero
it's also one that you will find has a
surprisingly deep and profound view on
life happiness and purpose
and so what I've learned is that one
punch man is such a masterpiece because
it resonates with you not on one but
exactly four levels of meaning level one
the parody saitama is [ __ ] hilarious
if you've ever watched any of my videos
you'll know that I absolutely love
Shonen an anime the Epic fights the
tragic backstory is the inspiring
training arcs the mentor guy with the
white hair who is kind of cooler than
the main character I love it all the
problem you might have realized is that
this description basically fits every
single anime out there and now we have
two things that we absolutely do not
want predictability and repetitiveness
what made one punch man an instant
success even with the very first episode
is that it brutally makes fun of the
typical hero hell the name of the anime
itself is a parody one punch man a story
about a guy who defeats any enemy in an
instant starts with the hero where all
other stories ends at the Pinnacle of
the world the strongest of them all and
it's usually the story of how we got
there that is so damn exciting all the
Blood and Tears that were shed along the
way all the obstacles and enemies that
had to be defeated and all the
relationships formed along the way all
of it to become the strongest in order
to change the world now saitama is a guy
who used to work at a convenience store
who then decided to become a hero for
fun
he never had any major motivation for it
and the most struggle he actually went
through was doing a basic daily workout
routine well that and losing his hair
which is actually pretty brutal but at
the start of the story he's pretty much
an average guy who just sort of got
motivated to do something great but
actually succeeded right away and so for
anyone like me who has suffered through
endless training arcs and dead loved one
die so I guess the main character gets a
power-up scenes this is just a hilarious
thing to see now the true magic however
lies in the fact that every single
character and one punch man is written
as 100 serious except saitama everyone
is designed to fit perfectly into some
of your typical Shonen anime Trope
General Scotto and Moomin writer are
textbook examples of Shonen protagonists
all with their own struggles and the
will to become stronger
foreign
with bang you have the powerful wise
mentor and pretty much every single
villain whether Miner or major would fit
perfectly as a serious opponent in any
other story pretty much all of the
characters have unique and cool designs
tragic pasts and complex motivations and
most importantly everyone is drawn
seriously and act seriously except
saitama
he's a pretty boring average dude that
is purposefully lazily and comically
drawn and yet since he is the strongest
of them all he stumps on all the
accomplishments of these serious
characters around him take for example
Moomin Rider with his courage in the
face of an enemy that out-matches him
completely
we see him suffer and still get up over
and over again proving all the qualities
we want in our typical hero I got so
excited for him defeating the enemy
against all the odds but just when you
feel that the hard work and True Grit
will pay off movement Rider is defeated
in a single punch and it is no other
than saitama who arrives late to the
scene and then effortlessly saves the
day thinking to himself
listen on there no
no
no
basically the character that I now spend
all this time relating to and identify
with gets defeated in an instant while
all my hopes are undercut by one
effortless punch and it is so incredibly
funny because I know exactly that the
anime is making fun of my expectations
on purpose and I realized that the same
happens with the villains as well Dr
Janus exiled from the scientific
Community has spent 50 years of his life
trying to unlock the key to Humanity's
Evolution
finally creating the powerful and
mentally unstable creature Carnage
Kabuto a creature fully taken in by his
own power and Perfection and yet all the
build up we get and the characterization
for both of these great antagonists is
once again undercut right away when
Kabuto actually gets saitama to reveal
the secret of his incredible power
usually a fantastic opportunity to
depict a character's mental and physical
developments it turns out to be a simple
workout routine
[Music]
the ease with which he reached the top
and defeats all enemies robs all of the
supporting characters like genos of any
meaning they've derived from their
struggles the rate at which one punch
man keeps subverting common anime and
superhero tropes is just pure greatness
I think saitama just has this ungodly
amount of power and the worst or I guess
best part about it is that he didn't do
anything special to deserve it he isn't
the chosen one or an underdog who has
sacrificed everything to get to the top
he really is just this 25 year old guy
who's unsatisfied with work and so I
can't help but laugh my ass off every
single episode as a result of this let's
go to level two but first I pray real
quick I want to say thank you to
Squarespace who's the sponsor of today's
video thank you Squarespace if you've
ever thought about making your own
personal website and actually have that
website look good despite having no idea
how to make one Squarespace gets you
covered they have a ton of wonderfully
designed web design templates that you
can customize to create your very own
professional looking website with no
prior knowledge whatsoever head over to
squarespace.com to try it out and once
you're ready to launch use my link in
the description below to get 10 of your
very first purchase of a website or
domain level 2 the social critique
Shonen is predictable Obsession corrupts
and life without a challenge is
pointless once I started to dig a little
bit deeper into the comedic surface of
one punch man I quickly discovered that
many aspects of the anime are quite
critical of the current status of Shonen
anime the concept of superheroes in
general as well as the societies that
these stories take place in the first
and most obvious message I found is once
again directly connected to the premise
of the story saitama is a man who has
obtained absolute power
because he's the strongest he's able to
defeat one and boss level monster after
the next something every other hero
dedicated his entire being towards and
yet at the end he's as dissatisfied as
he was working a regular job life is
dull without a challenge
when there are no stakes and no
consequences to fear for anything we do
life becomes less enjoyable beginning
the story as a delusioned young man with
a full head of hair searching for a job
in business saitama discovers a passion
for hero work that for the first time in
his life lights a fire in his eyes but
three years later The Thrill Is Gone
along with his trademark anime hair and
he has gained the power to end any fight
in just one punch even though saitama is
a really nice guy he has fallen prey to
his own desires and expectations after
all his great wish to become a hero in
the first place was because he thought
it was fun finally something he could do
that he's actually good at whatever
and so even though he usually does the
morally right thing he doesn't fight to
save others he fights for his own
personal pleasure and since he already
is the strongest this obsession with
having a good fight leaves him
eternally dissatisfied this is the true
conflict in one punch man
[Music]
it is the central theme of the story
this obsession with the goal of becoming
stronger which typically sets Our Heroes
apart from the rest and allows them to
grow here is explore through a more
human and realistic lens take a moment
to really appreciate that the most
common way normal people turn into
monsters in this world is by succumbing
to their obsessions krablante for
example was so obsessed with eating
crabs that he turned into one Phoenix
man was obsessed with grief and with his
role in his canceled TV show so much so
that he merged with his bird costume
genos turns less and less human with
every single upgrade he gets
us
becomes more and more Monster the harder
he pushes all the way to a my mask who
is consumed by his desire to be
beautiful and so I started to get the
strong feeling that the lines between
humans and monsters get more and more
blurred as the story unfolds so once
again subverting typical anime tropes
the main theme is not about not giving
up in fact the story has made it clear
at several points that there are times
when a person really should give up it
is actually a story about staying human
that Insight really hit home for me when
I rewatched the last episode of Season
One Yoga
backstory is pretty much exactly the
same as saitamas he's an invincible
being that got so obsessed with a good
fight yet he started eradicating planets
in order to find stronger opponents he
is meant to be an exact mirror for
saitama's faults a warning for what our
bold hero might become should he find no
way to leave his obsession behind on a
larger scale I also found that one punch
man criticizes the concept of superhero
Societies in general how can creators
keep upping the stakes and make it
interesting for fans who've already seen
it all is there a point where it all
kind of starts to feel recycled in the
world of one punch man this is expressed
in the form of the hero Association
whose creation was actually sparked by
saitama himself when he saved a little
kid from the
cracks
as it turns out that he had a lot of
money however since saitama lives mostly
outside the system in general we get to
experience it for the first time side by
side with him I personally found that
the hero association's ranking system
and the Egos and internal strife within
it are a super interesting take on the
idea of superheroes as famous
celebrities the message here being power
doesn't corrupt it only reveals who you
were all along level 3 the life lesson
saitama teaches you what actually
matters in life you may or may not
believe me but the true message behind
one punch Man actually goes even deeper
than we've already gone far from being a
pure comedy show or simply criticizing
the status Quoin anime one has
intentionally planned his story to be
the real deal right from the start the
world of one punch man with its enormous
cities that are harassed by cataclysmic
monsters every other day is built
specifically so that saitama can work as
a protagonist a guy who punches big and
strong things on a daily basis that
makes it even more impressive to me than
how rich and real this world starts to
feel a few episodes into the story we
talked about all characters but saitama
being written completely seriously but
that does not only result in a comedic
effect but it also makes these people
feel real and relatable and we have a
lot of fantastic character arcs for
people like Janos godo and Sonic
their contrast to saitama is not only to
be funny they contrast him to shine
light on the true point of one punch man
as a story drawing him as simply as he
is has the really fascinating effect
that we have to judge him not by his
appearance but by his actions and
personality no epic hair and no bad ass
costume saitama is so special as a main
character because people love him for
just being himself wanting to be the
strongest is something that only very
few people can actually relate to
worrying about money what to have for
dinner and procrastinating important
stuff we have to do on the other hand
pretty relatable watching TV and playing
video games on a Tuesday morning also
extremely relatable saitama is easy to
love as a character because power
reveals who someone is at heart and
saitama is just this nice but sort of
Clueless dude in his 20s and it's no big
surprise to me I think that this is
extremely attractive to people
[Applause]
[Music]
most importantly however saitama's big
flaw as a character might be the most
relatable thing of them all he is
obsessed with the thought that being a
strong hero will make him happy will
fulfill him and yet once he gets what he
wants it doesn't the real journey of
saitama is not finding someone that he
can have a real fight with once that
happens it would just be straight back
to dissatisfaction two days later it's
saitama realizing that he needs to move
on from his fantasy and actually become
a Great Hero character wise finding
happiness in the Moment by spending time
with people like genos and finding
purpose in his ability to protect
humanity and Inspire others funnily
enough it is actually King who
summarizes the goal of one punch man as
a series perfectly
[Music]
here's another video for you to watch